all right
okay uh
uh let's go a little deeper into the yin
and yang aspects okay
uh some of it was coming up yesterday
but I would like for you to understand
it the more energetically and
spiritually
and then tactically
okay
so a thing that I've long said is
um well let's go back to the sparring
video what I would what I was describing
was uh you're going to connect to the
center right which you can do because
he's going to give you young energy as
he's trying to attack you in this
sparring video okay everyone understand
that right okay no matter what you might
not use spinal displacement but there is
Young aspect present there's young
aspect present right now okay and if I
match that level of young ass if I
internalize that
and match it we're going to adhere
does that make sense that's what's gonna
happen okay
and uh what I do with his aggression his
aggression is ego tripartite mind
therefore it's going to be filled with
tension it's going to have some
um of the repulsion attraction
behavioral pattern in it okay and that's
going to be your young aspect regardless
of spinal displacement that you can
adhere to by matching it internally okay
and with that all I did was get him to
tilt
going back to yesterday's video I told
you you don't need a lot of tilt that's
enough tilt okay and Marshall
application it's not going to be this
it'll be that
got it and all throughout that video of
Aikido and sparring
he would until himself do you see that
okay and so while you're here and it
looks like yeah I'm just gonna Ed me and
I guess you could uh if you're strong
enough but it's not Jiu Jitsu at that
point okay you're gonna wait for him
to counter the initial kazushi do you
understand
okay uh and so because you have the
center the center connection he's never
totally free of what he's going to do so
when he counters it you move in his
Center into and past the posture that he
wanted and because he went from here
as opposed to here to here he went from
here to here do you see that he's going
to there's going to be more young aspect
at that point when he re resists that
greater angle in his posture okay and so
he'll do something else to try to gain
his posture you see so here he moved his
base of support back under his line of
gravity well now you have
the throwing energy that you saw me
utilize at times
does everyone understand that process
okay
all right so
it is attack was that fear ego
tripartite tension Young
in his kazushi correction it's present
again and that's why you can do your
Aikido there
understood okay
um
that is also why is
when he does the prescribed spinal
displacement you generate all that it's
just automatically generated in the form
by telling him uh you have to push do
you see
there's a tension in his body so I don't
know I I don't you can't do it so don't
freak out but have your arms super loose
it never holds positional Integrity on
the 12-6 line
do you understand and now push with your
body though
if you see the arm just goes back do you
see that
there's nothing I can do
he does that again there's nothing I can
do
in with that lack of inertia going
forward okay
so I'll do I'll do uh he he goes he
pushes and I do and it's very limited
the fact do you see
on eco
does everyone understand
what he locks his body he locks to his
arm then big effect
I understand
okay
I've also mentioned before that and
going back to this foreign video but
tying into things that I said before uh
the person
who let's say we're here let me ask you
a question is there a Chris I'll ask you
is there a young aspect present
yes yes it's just not as Amplified do
you understand you make your arm loose
there is Young aspect present the
gravity the friction his weight do you
understand even though there's no
inertia
just amplifies it for you to work with
but there's still there's still a a uh a
young aspect that I can still match it's
just at a lower level
you see so you can get it to go do you
understand okay
so
now
Okay so
uh go back to the sparring we got to
some tie up at some point you see and
you you felt that do you see that did
you feel it yes okay but you were
allowed to counter right so you would
counter do you see and he undid the hoof
you got it
but he felt his balance being taken
that's why he countered do you see
and in that he generates the young
aspect it's just going to be somewhere
else in his body okay so let me as soon
as you feel me start to take you off
balance that I want you to uh see if you
can find it in in your body okay
did you feel your hand tighten up do you
see
so you'll go you'll press here he'll
disarm but he tightens up
somewhere else do you see and and your
ability is to find the next
Amplified young aspect manifestation
otherwise
as you guys have done a million times
in the Coq game you're just chasing
things around you see so he goes he
tries to get off of it you can find it
somewhere else
everyone understands that problem that's
a problem right you guys cannot when we
go live and the person's allowed to
counter you cannot feel
where the Amplified young aspect is
somewhere else in their body and you
start chasing empty things
all that salt for you Kiron Wasa because
he is by prescription giving an
amplified young aspect and not allowed
to do anything else do you understand
when that when we go back to this
example okay and he feels that and he
goes to counter it and put your your
clinch back on okay he goes to counter
it do you see that when I say this is
the young Amplified aspect I'm saying
all that I said before the ego
tripartite fear fear uh attraction
repulsion behavioral pattern is here
do you under do you understand that okay
if I punch that person
in all likelihood he's gonna tense up
okay why because of the concentric
nature of fear ego tripartite mind and
tension do you see and if I hit him
if he's not trained it'll trigger his
ego tripartite mind and he will tense up
want it and then you'll have young
aspect throughout his body
and an amplified rate that you could do
something with
so uh some of the things that we've done
on that
is
um in the law enforcement
so when we pull
[Music]
we pull and I hit
then there's a stiffness in his body so
there's a pole right he'll loosen up
because he wants to get rid of the
the thing that's pulling them you see so
at first I have and then I'm just gonna
hit him in that chest and most people
will stiffen the hell up so boom
and then a little tiny sweep on the
bottom works even though there's a knee
hinge a hip hinge and rotational hinge
do you see that why does he fall like a
board because on the impact he tensed up
and stopped the articulation potential
of each one of those joints so for
example let's not hit him all I did was
a step like that
okay
and I'm not going to hit you you relax
relax as much as you can
it's not gonna happen his body is
twistable do you see
if he didn't twist he could take it in
his knee
it's not gonna go down
you understand
okay
this is why in your own
budo uses fear
and pain
and falling
and you could not being in control
to cultivate the spirit because every
one of those incidents will generate
that concentric grouping I just
mentioned ego tripartite line tension so
as you bring stress
you now have a chance to adapt yourself
to not respond not react with that
concentric grouping okay same thing goes
on knock his side
when you go your young young Clash all
that consensual grouping is present
again okay just like in sparring in the
sparring day I mean you guys are going
here and he makes that arm dead you're
trying for that as opposed to wait it's
gonna show up again later
go to there right
or enrolling in nawaza you're trying to
force techniques you're trying to force
them and you're getting swept in the
process because you make your body stiff
and you get swept that way okay it's
used against you
again as I mentioned only untrained
people do that so I I don't care if you
actually wear aquava
right and you're at a dojo and you train
it in an art what I mean by untrained is
you are still unconsciously controlled
by that concentric ego tripartite
grouping okay
um
so it's not uncommon as I saw for
example
a a video where you unders where that
was understood
not in this way but understood enough
that if I hit something that he will
tense up
okay
so I'm going to I'll I'll hit and it
makes his arm tense okay most people not
trained people most people boom I hit
his arm there'll be attention boom and
then you can do a sumitosh variation but
do you understand okay so it's got to be
a two beat
right if I just go here I kind of maybe
I got it because he's holding it himself
if you want you can relax and I'll lose
it okay but I hit boom and then you can
get it to go do you understand okay so
your goal of hitting is not to knock it
down your goal of hitting is just to
spark that tension in his body and then
use that tension to utilize this ledge
here do you understand
for you to push
okay try it
answer questions okay
so I saw that I was able to take his
balance right to shikaku and just
dipping the elbow out and you're gonna
get his balance in sumitosh right corner
drops okay now let's understanding the
concentric grouping
what allowed that to mechanically
function
you guys tell
you got to go deeper because it's a
concentric group
what allowed that to happen you see
the rising simultaneously with it
becoming a leverage point
okay
in other words it's not a leverage Point
If It Moves In Space
do you understand so something kept it
in space
simultaneously with it becoming a
leverage point what else happened
yeah the tension in his body and
simultaneously with the tension in his
body the fear the fear do you see that
and simultaneously with the fear
okay he's on that behavioral pattern of
avoidance and desire right he was
Desiring to not go down that made him
push back on it okay uh he's attracted
to uh uh so he's attracted to not going
down and he's trying to avoid going down
and it brought tension into his body
okay and then what else is also
simultaneously happening once you have
all those things as an aggregate as a
combination of things
how do I describe that
the ego tripartite mind is functioning
fully okay uh if you look and again as I
said it's untrained people who do that
okay that's a fear response that's an
untrained body mind okay our our
reduction to the ego tripartite mind is
an untrained person that's what it means
by definition okay it doesn't have
anything to do with your right or how
many techniques you study or how much
you go you're currently untrained
got it okay uh because you if you take
away
even one segment of that aggregate it
all goes away
because it's concentric it all goes away
okay so if you look at it and he goes to
hit it
it's The Three Stooges
do you understand it's my it's my
reaction that I give it just enough that
he can start leveraging them it's the
same thing when he goes to push the
shoulder a little cross push he goes to
push the shoulder I step backward if you
paid attention there was a moment I got
heal waited you see and that had to
impact on my line of gravity
why did I do that because I have tensed
up and resisted
If he if I don't resist and I let him
push me
it just triggers the other movement you
see you guys see that okay this is one
reason why
from Campo to my Aikido you always work
with the angle cancellation
so you would not hit down because you're
not checking Heights do you understand
and the same thing you would not so you
would not hit in one dimension because
you don't check the other aspect of that
Dimension and then same thing here he's
going horizontal you don't check the
other side of that Dimension which would
be my cross lateral side okay so
um when you go for example we're here
and I go I go to here do you understand
I have to understand one there's that
high and I'm not going to let that arm
Escape so that it goes down and around
and hits me back so I have a check here
right and my cut has that little jerk
you see when I take his height it's boom
simultaneously out so I get that cross
battle aside and then here is where you
would do your attack you get do you
understand that everyone makes sense
okay uh if we bring that angle
cancellation that's what we call it
where you're cutting diagonals through
height width and depth we bring that
into every single Technique we do here
so you look for it every time okay
all right
there are other ways without it being a
matter of a fear generated response that
you can have this work as a leverage
point
okay
the first way is he's actually lifting
up his arm
so you have your knife
right so you can do a step two his arm
is lifting the elbow's lifting do you
see that
so as it's lifting
in his intention to lift the knife it
creates The Leverage there and we want
to understand okay
uh another way is that youth rotation to
generate
that positional Integrity that you could
use okay so uh the first one as he's
coming up
you're going to take it out so let me
show you I'm not hitting it first I'm
not going boom and then out
as it's coming in
I'm kicking it out
got it in and mix admit I miss its
intention to come up and stick it
so it's in who
then the other one is the inertia so
he's going that way do you see
I keep on going that way and as I turn
it and now I'm doing the same thing
it's going forward and out on the
rotation therefore as I go rearwarded in
it has positional Integrity to my Ed me
okay everyone with me so I'll do it one
more time boom
on the other one this way move
okay and I want you to feel
oh it doesn't have anything to do with
his psychological
inability to free himself from his ego
tripartite line okay we're operating one
at the level and tension and two we're
using rotational inertia to give the L
positional Integrity for projection we
are increasing the Yong aspect that's
what we're doing that's what I mean by
positional Integrity so that I can use
it to throw okay try it so let's go back
on on
there's there's two ways of doing this
with two different Force engines okay
uh there's the first one where you hit
you wait for a reaction and then you've
increased the young so you have
positional Integrity in the joint
meaning The Joint loosen the joint won't
open and nor will this joint allow it to
rotate do you understand do you never
understand that okay uh I don't think
you do so if he pushes down nope you're
gonna do that hand you're gonna push
down if my elbow joint is allowed to
function his energy is dispersing and
disseminating out the bottom of that
articulation it will not pull on my
Center there's not no energy effect in
my Center okay
same thing he pushes on it and I free my
shoulder joint it will not go into my
Center okay
if you combine the two boom
you're trapping Etc okay
um
why did it work because the fear
response the egocentric ego tripartite
functioning a palm being hit I am the
one who locked my shoulder articulation
and my elbow articulation making this on
external ledge that could be overpowered
and then take my Center that's what
happened I did that externally okay
but what I said was there's young
aspects already here
okay
and you can you just have to match it
that's all you have to do so you can
make your elbow loose your shoulder
loose if I overpower it that's how you
get that other stuff but if you don't
overpower it you can move him
so you won't loosen your arm just loosen
it and get out of it
but I keep it
you feel the friction go every time you
move I have to change it do you see that
because the tension goes somewhere else
I cannot overpower the young as in that
first engine otherwise you have to
resort to those
cycle I call them psychological tricks
of the unskilled they only work on the
unskilled okay so instead I'm matching
him and I can now move him
do you understand okay
in other words
um
when this refused to articulate and
disrefuse to articulate you could say
it's young at the 10th power young at
the 10th power
got it okay so now I can do young at the
10th power
if I if I could do y'all to the
hundredth power the arm would bend and
the shoulder would do as well okay I
kind of made him match my intention but
you don't have to who can match this
which is Young to the first Power I
don't know yawn to the second power I
kind of matched that and you still will
get the effect on the center
everyone with me okay that's important
because
when you do the other one and you hit it
do you understand
you you you have to hope that your young
output is matching his young output you
can't predict it you didn't feel it you
just go boom and then you did it okay
also
when you pay attention and you hit that
with just external mechanical young
aspect what
has to be in place
for all that to work it's just so
obvious but it's so obvious you might
not notice it
yes
do you see that I can Crown to support
that young output so imagine me on
roller skates
do you get it it's not everybody hit
that thing and young to the 10th power
and I'm Gonna Roll Off
you see that or maybe some of you
experienced that on the first one so it
came out like this and you push and you
had to wiggle your toes change your feet
take a step do you understand or maybe
even on this last on this other one that
we're doing here
you are also wiggling your toes taking
stances rolling your feet those are all
that I'm not doing this internally and
therefore I can't work at lower levels
of young aspect okay
um so again we're here you ground
okay
as a side note because we saw this over
here
uh
a lot of times people do send me a toast
and you stabilize the elbow by over
prescribing UK to hold on
do you see that instead of I push and
they let go
right or you grab and now you've
positionally stabilized the elbow for
your mechanical external displacement do
you understand so you don't need to do
that in simulation script it's not
relevant to the throat
so the name
don't on my past don't grab
you're just passing boom okay try it
again
okay you feel the slip right so we're
over young so now I want you to pay
attention to your path of action
okay look go let maybe go slower Andrew
and you go slower Chris path to action
of the right hand okay
all it did was go back against the
strike do you see that okay and then
when you push
he just allowed for the articulation of
his elbow and your hand slips all right
do you understand okay
so in all of your Aikido it's not he
comes in and you do that
so the first let's go back
the first one keeps his hand coming in
and now he's pushed he's pushing on that
hat
I'm not gonna go here
I let him push
so try to watch the path of my hand of
this hand
[Music]
I reach out but I don't
y'all yet I reached out oh
it can be small just like edemina last
night it can be small
but it still happens okay it's not this
foreign
okay try it I'm just using this for
energetic reasons okay this is like for
example tactically this would have to be
like an ambush move the dude the dude
was here and oh you see and I I do that
tiny little angle and you'd be attacking
right so wow and then you drop
do you understand
that that's not a good knife technique
stand in the middle let a guy from a
step away come in
and do that kind of stuff you've got it
okay same thing about this technique is
he's coming around the only reason
that you would go back to the inside is
because he passed he's passing the knife
he's coming around he's trying to take
this one this one dude follow the energy
you see
you get it
so you would feel that
rather than yawning here
you'd pass it boom you feel it boom you
let it go past you and then again you
would do boom
show you what
but energetically it brings up what was
happening on the head in 18 August
yesterday
how am I touching the head am I moving
the whole Center
here it's the elbow
do you understand
so I just feel the elbow I want to feel
that
you see
it did not let it go off
feel it
[Music]
because they can be quick right you can
do the same thing
same thing
but I want you to feel the rotational
energy
and lastly for a second if you paid
attention
feel that
the hands are relevant whether it's a
finger or not this way or that not
relevant
okay try
so again as as I'm working the rotation
say that my feet have to be ground
vectoring so that I am able to not use
my external because you're almost you
have you have to over you have to over
yawn externally you have to that's why
the first solution was let me make his
yarn to young white at the 10th power do
you know that's why you needed that you
can't deal with lower level energies
okay
um but you need to know how to deal with
lower lower level energy or lower level
young aspects because that's what people
counter with
do you understand
okay so as as we're going around
you're you'll see it's ever so slight
it's ever so slight if I go anymore I'm
gonna go off so I stay at where I feel
that's as far as you can go and have
some relationship with his Center do you
understand do you feel that okay so that
I pass to here because in essence this
has reached its maximum young aspect I
can't go anymore and so I it's now
entering into its Yin face and so now I
pick up over here you feel that okay and
then I have the center again
it doesn't have to be a grab or anything
I don't even need a Ledge
I just have to not do more young than he
that position is doing same thing here
it does not have to be this hand
it does not have to be this hand it does
not have to be a hand at all okay I just
have to match the yawn that he's given
foreign
and that has to be
I have to have as Chris said I have to
have positional integrity at the ground
I can't be bouncing all over the place
so I can't video
[Music]
my body push
you see push
do you think I moved
push
[Music]
again it's not strike here's my finger
push
that's not what's happening okay
then as you guys know here you smell the
throw
he will change Audrey Lucan will change
to some degree we feel that's coming off
running just a little but if I continue
with the relationship it's back on
he changes I make it back on
you see
why you guys are losing the arm is
you're not grounding you're not using
rebounding young aspect
and you're over yawning
and you're not adapting
as he starts to fall you just aim right
here
your hand slides down
it's the relationship
the relationship
[Music]
the mechanical external placement is
irrelevant
so you're feeling
I had to go this way to not fall off his
arm and go and catch it at the bottom
as he starts to turn around
turn it even more
as he starts to do that
you see
you stay with the relationship
okay there's only a counter
if you break the relationship
if you don't break the relationship he's
only moving deeper into the void okay
try it again